[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be discussing a popular
what if scenario that harry potter fans
have been asking
for years what if harry had accepted
draco malfoy's handshake
in the philosopher's stone let's dive
right in shall we
a memorable event both in the novel and
on the big screen
although the setting is a bit different
in the film almost anyone who's familiar
with harry potter
knows of this moment in the book it
actually takes place
less than 100 pages into harry potter
and the philosopher's stone
so what significance does it have
exactly basically
if harry had chosen to take draco's hand
at the very beginning of the first book
it likely would have altered the course
of the entire series
first let's start by taking a look at
what happened in this scene
harry finds himself in a travel
compartment on the hogwarts express
with a somewhat shy yet friendly ron
weasley as they make the journey from
platform nine and three quarters at
king's cross station in london
to hogwarts for the very first time
harry and ron have just exchanged
introductions
when draco flanked by his friends crab
and goyle
entered their compartment to see if it's
true that the harry potter is inside
of course this isn't the first time
draco and harry have encountered each
other
they had a strained exchange at madame
malkin's rope shop in diagonally while
shopping for school supplies
but now that draco knows that harry is
harry potter he's showing a lot more
interest in him
and so after insulting ron due to his
appearance
red hair freckles shabby looking must be
a weasley
draco offers what i believe is meant to
be his best piece of advice
along with his outstretched hand you'll
soon find out some wizarding families
are much better than others potter you
don't want to go making friends with the
wrong sort
i can help you there he held up his hand
to shake harry's
of course in the book harry quickly
rejects this offering
with the sentence ending with but harry
didn't take it
but what if he had what if in that
moment
he had hesitated ever so slightly paused
just long enough to think
well what's the harm in keeping my
options open who really knows
who these two boys are who's to say that
ron weasley would make a better ally
than draco malfoy
in this new and intimidating world i
found myself thrown into
and so instead of immediately rebuffing
draco and making an enemy
he reaches out and meets draco's hand
perhaps he does so while looking at the
floor and even blushes a little
feeling a bit ashamed for not standing
up for ron who has just been so nice to
him
and when draco takes his leave of the
compartment he avoids ron's eyes for the
remainder of the journey
they sit in awkward silence as an
unspoken divide begins to form between
the two
once they reach hogwarts and the sorting
ceremony begins harry listens to the
sorting hat song
along with the rest of the students
paying special attention to the
following
verses there's nothing hidden in your
head the sorting hat can't see
so try me on and i will tell you where
you ought to be students begin to get
sorted in their houses
and harry sees malfoy his new and
potentially only
ally become a member of southern house
so
what could be so bad about joining a
house with someone who's offered to show
him the ropes of the wizarding world
and then as if answering this thought
when harry is called up for his
placement
the sorting hat shares it could be great
you know it's all here in your head
and slytherin will help you on the way
to greatness no doubt about that
and instead of fighting it harry
embraces it thinking that doesn't sound
so bad
of course from there absolutely nothing
would have been the same
for our friend harry obviously the first
major difference would have been his
friendships at hogwarts
i had to have best friends in
sutherland's rival house of gryffindor
especially if you've slighted one of
those people before you even really got
to know them
ron and it's highly unlikely that
harry's new pal draco
would have accepted hermione granger a
mudblood or witch born of muggle parents
as acceptable company and so harry would
have continued to develop a friendship
with draco
this bond would have likely pushed crab
and goyle out of draco's immediate crew
who needs bodyguards friends when you
have the great and famous harry potter
as your bestie
due to draco's interest in quidditch or
at least his interest in being on the
team
harry may have still ended up playing
the sport but for slytherin house
perhaps he would have intentionally
ousted slytherin's former seeker
terence higgs in his first year at
hogwarts fueled by his developing
maliciousness or maybe he would have
waited until lucius malpoy
draco's dear dad donated enough nimbus
2001 broomsticks to the entire slytherin
quidditch team in their second year
resulting in both harry and draco being
welcomed onto the team
harry and draco may have fought over who
played seeker but something tells me
harry would have earned the role being
the talented and famous harry potter
in either case i think harry would have
still been enthusiastic about the game
of quidditch
just on a different team and so
similarly to his friendships
harry's other relationships also would
have been affected most notably his
mentors
instead of albus dumbledore hogwarts
headmaster the obvious choice would have
been the head of slytherin house
severus snape with harry's placement in
slytherin rather than gryffindor
perhaps snape would have sooner revealed
his past connection with harry's mother
lily and seen less of a resemblance
between harry and his dad
james who was of course a gryffindor
with snape as harry's mentor there would
have been little reason for dumbledore
to get so involved in harry's life
and progression through hogwarts as he
already would have had the guidance of
severus
and with draco openly referring to the
likes of hagrid as riffraff
it would have been unlikely that harry
pursued any further interactions with a
lowly
school game keeper harry's love
interests and romantic inclinations
would have also been impacted
hard to see him firing up a romance with
ginny weasley after so many years of bad
blood between harry and ron
which would have been a direct result of
the handshake with draco
i guess it's possible he may have still
had a relationship with ravenclaw's cho
chang but something tells me that this
version of harry would have been more
interested in someone a little less kind
and a little more ruthless like say
pansy parkinson
leader of a gang of girls from slytherin
house who were often associated with
draco and his crew
it stands to reason that pansy who was
seen to be romantically linked to
or at least interested in draco
throughout the series may have even
become involved in a love triangle
between malfoy and harry
if harry had been a suitor perhaps he
would have been the one to take pansy to
the yule ball
and the gobs of fire not draco from
there who knows what might have happened
with all of this in mind it makes sense
that if harry had accepted draco's
handshake on the hogwarts express
due to his fame and innate talent as a
wizard harry likely would have taken on
the role the draco plays in each of the
books replacing malfoy as the villain
as an orphan who lost his parents at
such a young age and who was badly
mistreated by his extended family for
his entire childhood
it really doesn't seem that far-fetched
that harry could have become
this series antagonist rather than its
protagonist
can't you just see it a malicious
version of harry replacing draco in each
of malfoy's scenes
perhaps he would have even been the one
sought out by voldemort to assassinate
dumbledore
which begs the question if harry had
become the villain who would have
carried out the adventures of harry
potter
who would have stopped professor
quirrell slash voldemort from getting
the philosopher's stone
who would have overshadowed cedric
diggory in the triwizard tournament
and who would have hunted down of
voldemort's horcruxes alongside ron and
hermione
well as it happens i have a theory about
that too guys
what if neville longbottom had been the
chosen one stay tuned for a future video
diving into this very topic which means
sadly
yes that's it for this video if you
enjoyed the content i'd be grateful if
you liked the video and subscribed to
the channel
as always happy to hear your input on
this and other harry potter theories
just leave them in the comments below
and please feel free to share any topics
you'd like to see
in upcoming videos you guys always have
great ideas
until next time scared potter
you